good evening I'm Becky Kerrigan with
burns and I when we thank you for being
with us tonight
jobs are something that's very important
to this area especially now is our
furniture industries and our textile
industries and tobacco industries are
all moving to other places but at what
cost we're very pleased to welcome
tonight Elaine Majed mejia
from the North Carolina Justice Center
who is going to introduce our guest
tonight thank you for joining us good
evening on behalf of the Justice Center
I'd like to welcome you all and thank
you for coming as you know and as Becky
just mentioned we're here this evening
to hear from author Greg cool Roy who's
founder and director of good jobs first
and we're going to hear about his new
book the great American job scam
corporate tax dodging and the myth of
job creation Greg's book is a
fascinating if not somewhat disturbing
expose on what happens when the desire
of elected officials to stimulate job
creation and the desire of corporations
to maximize profits intersect and the
modern merger of these two powerful
forces is generating unanticipated
consequences that should strike a chord
for all concerned citizens and taxpayers
and so without further delay out these
well help join me in welcoming grandpa
Roy thank you thanks very much Elaine
thanks very much Becky thanks very much
to Barnes and Noble here in Greensboro
and to Becky Kerrigan and her fellow
staff persons for hospitality this
evening and to all the staffers at the
North Carolina Justice Center Elaine
Mejia Diane Morris jamu dillahunt and
amnok Cameron for making this week
possible thanks to everybody else for
coming out on a summer evening to talk
about a an issue that's so important
there is a abroad in our land today a
scam a fifty billion dollar a year scam
the average state today subsidizes jobs
more than 30 different ways property tax
abatements corporate income tax credits
sales and utility excise tax exemptions
low-interest loans and loan guarantees
land writedowns infrastructure subsidies
training grants Enterprise Zones TIF
districts on and on
but it's not paying off it's got lots of
unintended consequences it's backfiring
in many ways it's decimating communities
by subsidizing interstate job flight
it's stressing out our health care by
subsidizing companies like Walmart that
freeload on Medicaid and Children's
Health Insurance 16 states have now
disclosed which companies get the most
money out of those systems with North
Carolina hasn't the scam is helping
create a massive tax burden shift away
from large corporations on to small
businesses and on to working families
its subsidizing private for-profit
prison companies like Corrections
Corporation of America
it's corroding state and local budgets
stressing everything from schools to
infrastructure it's the great American
jobs scam an intentionally constructed
system that allows companies to exact
huge taxpayer subsidies in the name of
jobs promising quality jobs but then
allows them to fail to deliver and the
other promised benefit often associated
with these deals increased tax revenues
often proves to be false or exaggerated
as well if you look up the names of
companies that have received taxpayer
subsidies in the name of jobs and almost
every big company has because they're so
easy to get and so ubiquitous chances
are you'll find many companies that have
failed to keep their promises companies
that have failed to create as many jobs
as they promised companies that are
paying poverty wages failing to provide
health care to their employees companies
that are banding our cities and
sprawling onto farmland and other
natural spaces even companies that are
offshoring and outsourcing jobs offshore
if you dig a little deeper you'll find
some companies that haven't created any
new jobs at all some companies that have
actually laid people off since getting
the subsidy others that have just gotten
paid to move existing jobs from one
place to another we're there now
proclaimed to be new jobs these scams
have crept into every form of taxes the
companies normally pay to support public
services income taxes property taxes
sales and utility taxes many deals
involves multiple subsidies eight or ten
or twelve subsidies in a single deal and
many deals routinely exceed $100,000 per
job corporate income tax credits have
grown so overgrown than in many states
now on new investments companies are
getting negative corporate income tax
rates for new
facilities they're generating net loss
carryforwards into future years or
income tax credits against income on
other properties subsidies have gotten
so overgrown that in some cases
taxpayers are giving companies tax
breaks equal to the entire cost of
building a facility or even more and
obviously the most glaring recent
examples right here in winston-salem
with the case of Dell computer work got
a package of state local subsidies that
may approach 300 million dollars for a
facility that the company said at the
time would cost it about a hundred to a
hundred and fifteen million dollars to
build in other words the state agreed to
subsidies worth about twice the cost of
the facility how do they get away with
this because the system is rigged
corporations have it down to a science
they've learned how to say to chant jobs
jobs jobs and win huge corporate tax
breaks and still really do what it was
they wanted to do all along I say rig
two because taxes and tax breaks don't
determine where companies expand or
relocate they can't all state and local
taxes combined as a cost of doing
business for the average company comes
it to just 0.8 percent of the company's
average cost of doing business it's the
business basics it's everything else
it's ninety nine point two percent of
their cost structure that really
determines where companies decide to go
this job scam system has a long history
and it has a lot of moving parts can be
traced back partly to the Great
Depression but it had really matured by
the 1970s by then most of the key actors
were in place secretive site location
consultants who specialized in playing
States against each other cities against
each other business climate experts with
highly politicized interpretations of
tax and jobs data and a corporate
network that was orchestrating attacks
on state tax systems today this system
has an even more elaborate cast of
characters rented consultants and
economists packing rosy projections and
dire forecasts subsidy tracking
consultants who literally specialize in
doing nothing but helping make sure
companies don't leave money on the table
subsidy has gotten so overgrown and
irrelevant the company decision-making
processes there a lot of companies don't
even know all the things they're
entitled to
so there's a whole niche of consulting
out there just to help companies make
sure they don't leave money
on the table that they didn't know they
were coming to do and even an embryonic
industry now were four states have
legalized the buying and selling among
companies of economic development tax
credits maybe we could overlook all this
chicane are--if all boats are rising but
I think we all know that we're not
getting higher wages better benefits a
stronger tax base or better public
services indeed for the last quarter
century in America for four out of five
workers all the non managerial workers
essentially as a group in America wages
have stagnated or fallen health care has
become less affordable and less
available pensions of shrunken number
and value cities and states in many
cases have developed structural deficits
prompting cutbacks and everything from
school programs to infrastructure
maintenance the only clear winners in
this system are the large corporations
with the armies of consultants and
accountants to help them gain the system
the rest of it the rest of us pay more
or the quality of our public services go
down and usually a little bit of both
and by the rest of us I mean especially
small businesses as well as working
families besides creating corporate
windfalls the great American jobs scam
is creating all manner of collateral
damage it was used to blunt calls for
trade reform long before NAFTA was on
the horizon it's harming our environment
by fueling sprawl sprawl and sprawling
land-use patterns it bankrolls
interstate job piracy and ironically and
tragically it's diverting money away
from things that really could and do
grow good jobs specifically skills and
infrastructure and just don't get me
started about stadiums or convention
centers somebody else wrote that chapter
this is not a partisan book because this
is not a partisan issue both political
parties are knee-deep in this scandal my
name just as many Democrats as
Republicans in my case studies Democrats
like your governor here Mike Easley and
Washington State Governor Gary Locke
former aide to Michael Dukakis John
Sasso in Massachusetts and a board
appointed by then Governor of Vermont
Howard Dean I also named Republicans
like then Governor George W Bush then
mayor Rudolph Giuliani then governor
James Thompson of Illinois and even then
Governor John Ashcroft of Missouri even
Ken Lay of Enron infamy gets to make a
cameo
of course North Carolina merits a lot of
space in any book about the economic war
among the states and I welcome your
feedback about my treatment of your
state in the South in general North
Carolina really is kind of a tragic
story in the history of economic
development incentives in America up
until 1998 your state followed a really
kind of stingy even-handed philosophy of
doing incentives there was really a mix
and an ideological mix of fiscal
conservatism here so that in essence the
state said we're going to keep our taxes
down we're gonna keep our regulations
down we're gonna try to focus on
improving our schools and our
universities and our roads and our
infrastructure we'll have a few kind of
general subsidies that are broadly
available to many kinds of companies but
we're not gonna do gold-plated special
deals for individual companies and that
worked that philosophy worked up if you
look at go back and look at the economic
statistics of North Carolina before 1996
you had a very high job growth rate it
had a low unemployment rate compared to
the national average one of the best
economies in the region as well as the
nation but then this tragic thing
happened where there was this
competition for the Mercedes deal in
1993 in the competition for the BMW deal
in 1996 North Carolina was on the on the
finalist list for both of those deals
right Alabama got Mercedes and a South
Carolina got BMW and the giveaway crowd
you know prevailed in Chapel Hill sang
up we've got a we've got to open the
candy store we've got to compete and
that's when you got the William S Lee
act and the first couple deals out of
the tubes said it all first first deal
out of the tubes one hundred and seventy
five million one hundred and fifteen
million dollars or 77 thousand dollars
for the FedEx Hub where more than
two-thirds of the jobs were projected to
be part time and the deal worth five
hundred thirty six thousand dollars per
job for the new core steel mini mill
under which the company will reportedly
pay no state income taxes for twenty
five years numerous studies have found
that these big giveaway programs are not
creating lots of jobs in the neediest
parts of your state indeed most of the
deals are happening in areas that are
already booming and have the
of course that's consistent with the
whole southern history frankly in the
political history broadly of this issue
in the country of politicians taking
credit for things that would have
happened otherwise
really parade jumping reports climbing
in my opinion we also tell the obscure
story of a company called fantasy
fantasy factory relocating service that
became the dominant site location
company in in the 40s and 50s and 60s in
America in an event here in the 70s in
North Carolina a company from
Pennsylvania called Brockway glass
decided it was going to move 300 jobs to
Roxboro North Carolina looks like kind
of a typical runaway you know Rust Belt
the Sun Belt story right
but then the rocks both rocks bore city
fathers aborted the deal they
disapproved of the fact that the company
accepted a union and paid good wages and
apparently indicated it might do the
same when the jobs arrived in Roxboro
North Carolina well word got out and
people in Roxboro were ticked to lose
the good jobs and the County
Commissioners disgraced resigned on mass
the story prompted Fanus the site
location consulting firm to say
approvingly there there were literally
scores of companies that have been
turned away from southern towns because
of their wage rates or their union
policies in one chapter I focus on
property tax abatements and how they
harm schools and other public services
school boards in North Carolina like
most other states are powerless when
other bodies of government grant
companies long term property tax
abatements now families move into areas
with high housing costs and higher
property taxes in order to gain access
to good schools taxpayers vote for
school bonds at a very high rate and
companies like the locate in areas with
good schools - that's a good amenity for
their employees they want to recruit
good workers coming out of good school
systems the trouble is companies often
get a 10 year tax holiday for moving
into their preferred school district
families don't get the same break right
so guess who picks up the slack guess
who has to make up the difference in
fact I would argue that undermining your
property tax base in the name of a good
business climate is really just the
opposite it's really undermining your
business climate because skilled labor
is the
number one site location advantage in
America that's consistent if you look at
the literature from people who make
their living advising companies about
where to expand their locate this idea
that you can have this inter government
or free lunch where one body of
government undermines the school revenue
base in the name of a good business
climate I think is actually harming the
business climate I also spend a chapter
talking about how Economic Development
subsidies fuel suburban sprawl it's not
just the 1 billion dollars in
bricks-and-mortar subsidies that we
found have been given to Walmart stores
and warehouses it's not just a hidden
taxpayer cost like Medicaid and
children's health insurance
it's the insanity of subsidizing
anything and wealthy booming suburbs and
the incredible stupidity of subsidizing
retail space often using subsidies that
were originally created to help areas
that were blighted and depressed
subsidies that frankly have become
perverted over time as once Civic wagon
the Twin Cities put it subsidizing
economic development in the suburbs is
like paying teenagers to think about sex
I cite the case of a wealthy st. Louis
suburb which declared its local mall to
be blighted even though it was a very
profitable mall that was almost a
hundred percent rented and was grossing
more than 100 million dollars a year in
order that the mall owners could give a
subsidy about 31 million dollars to
bring in a Nordstrom now it's not
blighted now that it has the Nordstrom
it's hardly an isolated case many states
allow booming areas to subsidize retail
including predatory retail like Walmart
they allow it even though we're swimming
in grossly overbuilt retail space far
more than any other developed nation and
PricewaterhouseCoopers estimates that
were headed toward almost 400 dead
regional malls the official euphemism as
gray fields that's not an counting
that's not counting dead big-box stores
which are known politely as ghost boxes
these subsidies for sprawl are
symptomatic of a broader issue I raised
throughout the book about how economic
development subsidies have grown
indifferent to the issue of reducing
poverty I also cite a study in which we
looked at every single economic
development subsidy program on the books
in all 50 states to see do any of them
favor jobs that are accessible by public
transportation do they deliberately
create initi for people who cannot
afford a car
the answer is zero not one single state
program even gives preference to much
less requires that the jobs be
accessible by public transportation this
50 billion dollars a year spent on all
these job scams is not just precious
money wasted it has real costs to our
economy and to our future prosperity
it's undermining things that really do
pay off for good jobs especially skills
and infrastructure after chronicling all
the harms of these tax dodges and the
costs they create to public services I
argue that we have a broad and chronic
skilled labor shortage on the horizon
due to the mass retirements of the baby
boom generation which began really in
2008 that's when people in 1946 turned
62 and start to hit the exit doors in
very large numbers and I report what the
civil engineers have been telling us
about our infrastructure for years that
we have an enormous infrastructure
deficit affecting everything from
bridges and locks and dams to our public
schools our water grids our water
treatment systems and our power grids
if we don't restore our tax base to fix
that deficit we will suffer economically
for good infrastructure is critical to
everybody's productivity and public
health I also say in an era now where we
are suffering capital mobility right
we're manufacturing jobs are leaving in
service sector jobs are leaving because
of offshore outsourcing we've got to
save our money for things that don't run
away and at the top of that list always
would be skills and infrastructure the
good news also as I conclude is that the
taxpayers are fighting back a motley
rainbow of groups including social
service advocates community groups
unions and labor Federation's tax and
budget watchdogs like the North Carolina
Justice Center environmentalists have
won a series of state and local reforms
that are rewriting US jobs policy from
the grassroots up elected officials in a
bipartisan fashion are wisely heating
their constituents demands and again I
name a few laudable elected officials
from both side of the political aisle
first and foremost of these reforms is
disclosure annual company-specific
reporting of costs and benefits for
every company for every deal that's now
the law in 12 states most recently one
in Illinois Washington State North
Dakota
four states including North Carolina
actually put some of their data on the
web and on the back of the handout sheet
I've given you we actually give you the
website where you can look up disclosure
data as it exists here in North Carolina
I think we need more disclosure I think
every publicly traded company should
report to shareholders every year how
much it pays an income property and
sales tax in each of the 50 states then
we would see the real extent of
corporate tax dodging by the big
companies wouldn't you like to see Dells
numbers a couple of years from now see
how much or how little they're paying on
all their tax bills in North Carolina
next clawbacks literally money-back
guarantee language saying that if a
company was paid to create a hundred
jobs but they only create 50 taxpayers
get half the money back sounds intuitive
sounds common-sense
it still doesn't apply to a lot of deals
job quality standards that is companies
being required to pay a certain wage
full-time hours healthcare so that
taxpayers are not getting stuck with
hidden taxpayer costs of medicator
children's health insurance it's been
computed for instance that the average
Walmart store of 200 employees cost
federal taxpayers more than four hundred
twenty thousand dollars per store per
year in hidden taxpayer costs of social
safety net programs for the low-wage
workers at the store other coalition's
are demanding budgeting reforms so that
hidden corporate tax entitlements are
reviewed every year on an equal footing
with appropriations school boards are
becoming more aware that they deserve
more say when property tax abatements
and other subsidies hurt the school
budgets and activists against sprawl and
Walmart are increasingly saying no to
subsidies from nor for more sprawl
Mart's finally despite all the troubling
news about the afl-cio the last few
weeks I'm proud to say that labor is
united on this issue of cracking down on
corporate tax scams both afl-cio
president john sweeney and SEIU
president Andy Stern endorsed our book
we just didn't put them on the same page
thanks and I look forward to your
questions
please related to business incentives
coming out of Ohio and I was wondering
if you could tell us a little bit about
that sure it's company the case is
called Kuno versus DaimlerChrysler it
was decided in the Sixth Circuit of the
US Court of Appeals and is now on appeal
to the US Supreme Court in this case the
Sixth Circuit invalidated a very large
investment tax credit that the state of
Ohio gave dan where Chrysler for a new
Jeep plant in Toledo Ohio basically
under the Commerce Clause of the US
Constitution the court ruled that Ohio
was interfering with Interstate Commerce
by giving that tax credit and therefore
the tax credit is invalid under the
Commerce Clause the lawsuit that's been
filed here in North Carolina against
Dell partially rests on the same
constitutional theory as well you had a
question to can you learn from it to
make a change in all this well
absolutely I really spend the last
chapter especially focusing on reforms
and I touched on them a little bit here
disclosure money back gaurantee language
job quality standards or healthcare
rules I also get into more procedural
things for instance I think every single
deal should be voted on by people who
were actually elected by voters in many
places and in many cases appointed
boards who are not really accountable to
voters do these deals and I don't think
that's a smart a smart thing it makes
the whole process that much more
unaccountable to taxpayers and voters
and I'll say since the for the young
people in the audience tonight you know
this book really is about you a lot of
the subsidies being given out today will
continue lost you as taxpayers for years
and years and years they're going to
saddle you with with lousy or public
services and higher tax rates for many
years of your working life if we don't
fix this system it's about your standard
of living and the quality of life that
you will or will not enjoy based on an
adequate tax base right now we're giving
away our future reading our
seedcorn in many cases by allowing great
sums of money to be taken out of the
public systems for years into the future
I mean the Dell deal obviously for
instance would play out over about 15
years of revenue losses to the state as
an example property tax abatements ten
years at a crack tax increment financing
diversions in some states lasts up to
twenty three years so this really is
about the future of our economy and how
we're going to invest smarter for a
better future for you and your
generation please I think the real
victim in all this is the small business
owners the mom-and-pop stores the
landscape of the small towns I'm a small
business owner of myself and I've
watched a lot of my business go away to
the Walmart to the big super shopping
things is there any way to reverse this
trend is it possible to change this
trend well I just want to completely say
Amen to your point this is very much a
small business issue the small business
owners in this country do not have the
armies of consultants and accountants to
game the system to to write the rules
and then shoot the shoot the loopholes
in the systems that they they game this
is really about the big boys cashing in
and everybody else's expenses I have
challenged and I'll say it publicly here
I'm disappointed that in almost every
case except for a period here in North
Carolina the largest association of
small business interests the National
Federation of Independent Business
chapters have been missing in action on
this issue they've been publicly silent
and I think I don't get it I really
don't get it I think they're their
members are being hurt by this in a few
states now like Iowa and Texas they have
come out at least against subsidies to
Walmart or to sprawl Mart's because
they've got a lot of retail members who
are roadkill obviously when a Walmart
opens up but it's a much broader issue
than just retail Merchants I would also
say there's two alternative networks of
small business people that have been
formed perhaps in frustration on this
one's called the American independent
Business Alliance a MIB a.net on the web
and another one's called the Americans
small business alliance a sba and ET org
i believe is their website i'd recommend
both of them to you
there's a hand over on this side please
the same question I was wondering about
a legislation that might be pending
locally or nationally or if there are
there's a well-known national politician
it's a champion of this this sort of
thing being looked into or we wish
actually the only the only pending
federal legislation right now which has
been introduced in both houses in the
last few months is legislation that
would actually negate this lawsuit this
this Court decision I mentioned in Ohio
that's now on appeals in the US Supreme
Court the kyouno decision under the
Commerce Clause and I'm not an attorney
the Commerce Clause says Congress shall
regulate commerce among the states and
so there's a gray area here about who
really has the final word and Congress
or at least some people in Congress
think that they could they could moot
the case legislatively by legalizing
this crazy state each state you know
devil take the hindmost system which i
think would be a tragic mistake
I recommend in the book you know we did
we the federal government does lots of
things routinely to get the states to do
good for instance the federal government
withheld highway money to get all the
states to raise the drinking age to 21
and that saved a lot of lives we could
do the same thing with federal
Department of Labor money or Department
of Commerce money to get the states to
quit rating each other just cool off the
war we could we could do that it'd be
very simple wouldn't even take
legislation we'll just take some
leadership by the executive branch
saw in Vermont apparently if they have
effectively kept Walmart from building
more stores in Vermont by declaring the
entire state of historical location er
there are a few of Walmart's in Vermont
but all but one of them were actually
built in existing retail districts and
sometimes even occupying vacant you know
GC Murphy stores or something like that
the trouble is now they've announced
intentions to build I think seven more
really big stores like Super Centers out
on the fringe and their classic kind of
sprawling fringe footprint style and
that's when the National Trust for
Historic Preservation said you know the
whole state's an endangered zone if that
happens and so they're fighting them
it's it's a store buy store though just
like isn't so many other places please
Home Depot or a Walmart can come in and
take your land like like what's in the
news and everything now any private land
and also fits with my friend back there
was talking about how they can come in
and affect the small businessman you
know many years from now yeah great
point you're referring especially to the
Supreme Court decision that came down in
the New London case in Connecticut
legalizing the use of eminent domain for
economic development purposes where the
city is literally going to take private
land businesses and homes and give it to
another private owner they're not
building a highway they're not building
a school or a park they're just getting
a higher tax base by giving it to a
company for a corporate office park and
some other redevelopment activities this
case has drawn a great deal of attention
and a lot of proposed new legislation
both federal and state legislation to
restrict how cities can use eminent
domain and I'm very sympathetic with
people who are looking carefully at that
and and reacting negatively to what the
court ruled there on a narrow decision I
also think the the untold story of that
case in Connecticut and many other
places is to ask yourself why was the
city so desperate for tax base in the
first place and the answer in most
places is sprawl if you've had jobs and
people leaving an area for so long
it
makes the city desperate to get activity
back to the point we'll give away the
store they'll shove people out with them
in a domain if the tax base was healthy
if you hadn't had so much sprawl to
begin with if you hadn't been
subsidizing sprawl all those years you
wouldn't be so desperate and you
wouldn't need to use eminent domain
please when most of our part-time jobs
with no health care anything for the
workers I mean how can they count that
to their yeah great question you're
talking about Walmart specifically our
retail jobs yeah the whole issue of job
quality and retail is huge and look I'll
just say it this way except for a truly
depressed neighborhood that does not
have a basic grocery store doesn't have
a drugstore doesn't have a clothing
store I don't think we as taxpayers
should do any subsidizing of any retail
we've got way too much retail space
already and in it's not economic
development right I mean upstream ripple
effects of a Walmart are in China a lot
of them right and the downstream ripple
effects are almost microscopic because
as you say the jobs are part-time the
wages are poverty there's no benefits
people on those wages are not out buying
homes buying cars eaten out stimulating
the economy that's not economic
development so I just think we should
get out of the business of subsidizing
those kinds of jobs at all and and also
get out of the business of subsidizing
them through the backdoor through
Medicaid and Children's Health Insurance
there's a lot of program proposals out
there now so-called payer play
provisions that would stop all that
freeloading and I think that's a good
idea please as to all incentives or some
incentives no I'm not against all
incentives and I'm glad you asked that
question I think there are some valid
incentives to help clean up brownfields
and promote reinvestment and
rehabilitate affordable housing and help
people who have historically suffered
employment discrimination gain access to
better jobs and do things like that that
really do help us make more efficient
use of our tax base and our historical
infrastructure investments the trouble
is with the average state out there were
30 different incentives and talking
about enacting 31 and 32
instead of fixing the 20 out of the 30
that are broken most states are moving
in the wrong direction we got to cut out
the stupid ones hone the good ones and
keep those and protect our tax base
thank you for asking that so I should
have made that point in my talk place
think the answer the question that he
did you just answer the bottle you
against all incentives I think just by
good jobs first I think you explain
clearly why you're not against all the
sentence you just want to have good jobs
what motivated you to go out there and
you know fight for that and how can
other people do that you know this is a
completely accidental issue to me 20
years ago when I was living in Chicago I
helped create a consulting practice to
help people try to stop factory closings
was the whole wave of the Rust Belt
starting in the 80s in the recession of
80 80 to 83 and we started stumbling
upon many factories that had gotten tax
breaks in the past and and revenue bonds
and low-interest loans and other
subsidies but now the companies were
leaving and the jobs are being lost and
we would read the fine print of the
subsidy contracts and discover that it
was literally legal to take the money
and run and of course people went crazy
when we revealed that and that was
really the birth of clawbacks
in the wake of those plant closing
embarrassing revelations politicians
start enacting clawbacks as well as wage
rules and disclosure so it's really we
owe a great debt frankly to dislocated
workers in this country some of whom
kind of went down swinging to say never
never again am I gonna let taxpayers
subsidize job destruction and that grew
into a little book I wrote called no
more candy store that came out in 1994
which was a collection of some of the
earliest reforms and then I just haven't
been able to get away from it ever since
I've tried to give it away several times
believe me this book is another attempt
take my issue please
about your organization the good jobs
first organization you started and what
do you guys do in relation to this issue
we work with anybody who wants to help
reform economic development so mostly
grassroots groups community
organizations environmentalists labor
unions budget watchdogs
and with elected officials and and
public officials administering economic
development programs if they want to
adopt best practices like the best
reforms I talked about to improve their
programs we work with reporters we train
reporters that do investigative series
we published studies surveying national
trends on best practices like job
quality standards as well as state
specific studies we've done several
studies in New York City where we have a
project we did a very large study in
Illinois where we also have a project
office
and then we just train and testify and
and speak to help people get on board
and we're very happy I mean the truth is
at the same time there's been a lot of
bad money getting spent in economic
development there is a counter trend
there is a trend toward more
accountability taxpayers are fighting
back and we wanted to applaud and
acknowledge that as part of the book
please
this answer to this may entail a
summation of what you've said this
evening but if you had the ear of the
North Carolina General Assembly and in
terms of what it would take to create
the the skills and the infrastructure
that you had that has been a theme this
evening so that we can get off of the
tax incentive gravy train that's been
going on here in North Carolina what
would you tell the North Carolina
legislature to turn things around for
the common person here in North Carolina
well I would say a couple things I mean
I think public officials have to make
savvy market judgments about where they
stand and I'm looking a state like North
Carolina and I say you've got a lot of
natural advantages you've got a state
that's been attracting a lot of young
people and that's gonna be a big
advantage real soon when all of us
boomers start checking out you've got a
state with a high quality of life and
and a magnificent University structure
and historically a strong school system
that was a big public priority here
you've done some damage to your tax base
you've kind of veered off track for the
last nine years with this willingness ly
act nonsense but you know it's not
irreparable but she need to go back and
really recognize what it is of greatest
value you have and protect that so I
would set a phase-out of the big
giveaways like the Lee Act and and look
ahead to the way the money would get
reinvested in the way the state used to
reinvest it that paid off so well
historically skilled labor skilled labor
you know keep your tuition rates down
keep your eligibility high for your
vocal educational systems help your
people leaving welfare gain better
skills really work on your GED and ESL
programs and everything for incumbent
worker retraining programs for those
people have been dislocated by the plant
closings here because there's there's
gonna be opportunities and you will have
strong you will continue to have strong
comparative advantages if you play to
those strengths please example a company
would offer that you would call now
those are good jobs we should put some
money in that we should often incentive
because those are really good jobs that
really promote what would be an example
of that well certainly I come out of a
manufacturing retention background so I
think manufacturing is often more
justifiable than other kinds of activity
because it packs a great ripple effect
the wages tend to be better and the
upstream ripple effect tend to be better
because you're getting parts jobs for an
auto assembly plant or whatever the
trick obviously is to not over pay for
though any of those jobs whether it's a
good manufacturing job or not and you
want to write the contract in a way that
obligates the company to stay you want
to at the end of the day you want the
employer to be more ms2
to your public system more a mesh to
your workforce and more mesh to other
companies you want to spend the money in
ways that really makes the region
valuable on a value-added basis to the
company so that all of which is to say
you don't want to just do one special
deal with one company you want to use
the money in ways that gets the company
really tangled up and invested in your
public systems and in your economy that
metal make the jobs more stable and
frankly it's a strategy to from not
putting a lot of eggs in one basket look
any company can fail any company could
have a competitor come and take its
business away or some companies are
gonna run away it's just going to happen
we shouldn't be gambling a lot of money
with a lot of eggs in a few baskets
instead of investing in systems that
grow networks of companies and and make
more stable jobs that way great
questions please but in the tracking or
did you guys track that particular
incentives package and whether that on a
cost-benefit basis was that really a
benefit to Alabama to get Mercedes to
get there because that's cost them a
great deal of money over the since that
deal I hoped publicized a study that was
done after the Mercedes deal unfolded in
1993 and I'm convinced that the state
substantially overestimated the return
on their investment and and said that
they were gonna get their their
investment back much sooner than they
really did I think the deal took much
longer for the state to ever break even
on a taxpayer a basis I think the other
problem with Mercedes is that they have
begun to attract some suppliers you know
the number of auto parts jobs in Alabama
has also increased since they got that
assembly plant they've now attracted a
second assembly plant in Montgomery but
the trouble is they set up this
automatic entitlement system so that
everybody who comes to Alabama gets
these massive corporate income tax
credits and basically isn't going to pay
any income tax for many many years after
they arise so there's no such thing as
free growth right if you arrive and you
don't pay any property taxes and you
don't pay any income taxes but the
economy grows
well they gotta hire more teachers they
got to build more schools they gotta
widen the lanes they got to build more
sewer lines they got to pick up the
trash who's gonna pay for it I mean
everybody else gets stuck with higher
rates there's no such thing as free
growth and so there's really a
regressive squeeze going on on small
businesses on homeowners and on wage
earners in that state because the newly
arriving companies are not paying their
fair share
other everybody's convinced yeah I
really do welcome your reactions I mean
the South obviously is a central region
of the country on this issue some people
trace the development of these subsidies
back to Mississippi in the late 1930s
when a governor named Hugh white cooked
up the first state-sponsored
tax-free revenue bond program where the
the locality would actually own a
factory and lease it back to a company
it was a very lucrative arrangement in
which that obviously there was no
property taxes because the factory was
publicly owned and the interest rates
were very low because the financing was
done through a tax-free bond and then
that system really mushroomed throughout
the south in the 40s and 50s but I think
the tragic you know footnote to that
stories if Mississippi still ranks right
near the bottom if you look at personal
income statistics or educational
attainment or or personal health or
public health statistics after all these
years of giving away the store states
like Mississippi have really
impoverished themselves and not raised
people's living standards very much and
I think that's a lesson for all of us to
learn the trouble is too many states are
moving in the direction that Mississippi
started moving so long ago and just for
today's economy it's the wrong way to go
sorry
please
fifties I work in Massachusetts in
Lowell Massachusetts at the Lowell I
only like a textile Institute yep that's
good jobs came from the Merrimack River
textile mills to North Carolina for the
same reason they're going to China so
this as a matter of screw the worker is
not new in my country it's a basis of
the vitality of the cotton industry you
put your finger on something that you
can get specific about but this is a a
cultural I won't say spiritual but this
is a cultural and predicament that my
country is in the current issue the
September issue of Scientific American
devotes itself entirely to this and not
so much good jobs but poverty
the notion that we not have to stop
misusing a labor and that's what the
jobs do but we can't misuse water and
chemicals and air it's a this problem
that you put your finger on here it's a
crisis and an opportunity not just for
the young folks you know 80-some I feel
optimistic about this because I think
the people you're talking about have no
no alternative
we must be sees has no alternative but
to learn to be more concerned about
significant other and if you have a
concern about significant other you
can't screw anybody except the
significant other but III I'm optimistic
about this because that's I think what
we do when my country does it's just we
just celebrated a sixty year celebration
of a scam that created the industry of
weapons of mass destruction yesterday
that was a there was a scam bigger than
I'm from Houston that's bigger than well
no Enma the Manhattan Project but I
think I think we're we're moving in in
the right direction for reasons that I
can't explain
well I'll just refer briefly to one part
of a point you made a very eloquent the
the issue of attracting footloose
industries including textile industries
from the Northeast starting in the 50s I
think speaks to a real key point here
the business climatologist the people
who prescribed how states should go
about structuring their tax systems to
be attractive to business really we're
writing for the companies that were the
runaway shops for the Footloose branch
plants that were leapfrogging through
the south on their way to China or
Mexico
they weren't writing for the rest of the
economy and that's the trouble we're
still saddled with an ideologies that
was written for Footloose branch plants
and really didn't make sense and wasn't
applicable to almost every other kind of
employer in this country and those those
are the least loyal most at risk kinds
of jobs to subsidize and and it never
has served the region well in my opinion
please Research Triangle happened before
all that before 96 that was some
cooperation from what I understand of
people getting together the networking
you're talking about
did anybody really get an incentive I've
worked in the big IBM plant down there
did they get an incentive to build all
those I think 10,000 jobs yeah I don't
know the history of the Research
Triangle what I do know is that it's a
great example of investing in in
indigenous businesses investing in
infrastructure and connected companies
so that even if one fails the others
pick up the slack and you continue to
capture the benefit for the regional
economy it's actually an economic
development jewel I mean that the
presentations I've seen in the
comparisons to other you know think-tank
regions is it's one of the most
outstanding payoffs for economic
development of any state and it's and
it's a great counter example to the idea
of subsidizing a textile mill versus
investing in a Research Triangle there
are the opposite ends of the pole in
terms of smart policy versus dumb policy
please
briefly just I know you're not
originally from North Carolina but it is
important to know I think that the
Research Triangle part was created in
effect because of skill and
infrastructure needs because there was a
brain drain young people were being
educated at Duke NC State UNC Chapel
Hill area schools and then leaving for
other states and so the RTP was created
in that area to an in a fact take
advantage of the skill that the
taxpayers of North Carolina were
subsidizing to educate those people and
then export them to other states so I
think that's probably pretty that's a
good point that you brought up about the
RTP and what a different model that is
compared to the Dell deal right where
you're investing in a system rather than
a particular facility and what a great
payoff has had please yes sir when you
talk to politicians and other groups
that have some ability to cause this
positive change what's their typical
response you had a good response tonight
what happens when you're talking to the
politicians when I train for the
National League of Cities in the
National Conference of State Legislators
I actually get a very warm response I
get anger we do role plays where we talk
about how the scam plays out at the
local level and local officials are very
frustrated by this job scam system they
feel they're imprisoned in a game whose
rules they never would have written they
don't like the rules they want to
rewrite the rules they like the idea
that we can change the rules and and
make the system more transparent and
easier for them to do their jobs they
want to cooperate with each other they
want to cooperate in our self-interest
we get big turnouts let me put it that
way from the workshops that I offer both
of those organizations and and very
lively role plays
the story about the emergence of worse
it's a triangle has some context I was
working it at the inside 128 and 50s
late 50s when we were figuring out what
the hell is a transistor and it was a
good deal of what I now are called
military-industrial complex it's a
subsidy a good bit of which I think it's
appropriate but I also work in federal
systems division for IBM for about four
years as a research physicist and I was
a kept
lady I had an orange chair that's fourth
and that was I think a credible support
taxpayers were paying for all of that
the same way that taxpayers paid for the
Manhattan Project but that was the North
Carolina thing was to try to get some of
that stuff from Cambridge and MIT it
said all of that isn't a good mix of a
healthy a healthy competition much like
when the University of Chicago stole the
Graduate School from the school in
Baltimore but but I want to say we don't
know how to take some that leave some
that's a that's a big institutional
level the notion of robber barons fits
in here so we can do it small business
the big business doesn't matter we can
take advantage we're learning I think
we're learning I hope so I hope we
learned before it's too late before we
give away too much of our tax base
Scientific American deals with entirely
and can we learn in time
I think we are learning in time it's
difficult it's as difficult to be
pessimistic I think it is to be
optimistic but I think we have we are
learning big time but even with the what
do you a group of people we have inside
the beltway running please
myth of creating jobs here in the US and
what it's actually really doing I'm very
critical of NAFTA and CAFTA and I think
a couple of things I dealt with my first
one where I stopped to Mexico long
before and after back in the mid 80s but
it's an example of how worked this issue
of economic development becomes in the
wake of losing jobs due to bad trade
agreements some politicians say well
we've got to look active on jobs let's
do a big giveaway deal Dell or anything
else and my point is let's separate out
problem from solution and because
Washington is enacting bad trade policy
is not a reason to enact bad State Tax
Policy you know there is a thing called
the Forum on democracy and trade which
is a way that state and local officials
are gaining more influence in the trade
debate and exerting their their voice
with the trade representatives office
and the executive branch of the
government on trade agreements I think
we should be much more mindful of how
trade agreements affect not just local
economies but also states rights and
state and local economic development
policies many of which are potentially
vulnerable under trade agreements that
we've already signed so and then so we
should work on bad trade agreements at
the source in Washington but that's not
a reason to go back in an act you know
special loophole deals and scams at the
state and local level let's keep the two
things separate and work on the real
problems and real solutions together
please anybody making an effort to get
Congress to penalize companies for going
overseas is a good example understand
manufacturing is one thing but like
service sector where the credit card
people are sending all their service
people to India and things like that I
mean you're not competing against
something here that you had to go to
that country to produce something
cheaper to stay in the market you just
went there to make the bottom line
better why is it Congress and acting
penalties for going overseas when you're
not producing a job I mean you're taking
jobs away not because to stay in the
business it's just to make yourself
fatter great question there's been a
very it's mostly reform proposals on
outsourcing like that have been at the
state level and the companies that
profit from outsourcing have been
incredibly aggressive and vociferous
pushing back on such proposals even on
you know privacy related issues even on
security related issues for instance and
some proposals in California the the
companies have been very aggressive
resisting such reforms even modest
reforms like requiring people when they
answer the phone to state where they are
so that you even have a right to know
where the work is being done we did a
study in which we revealed that at least
42 or 43 states offshore their food
stamp debit card work overseas but the
average state doesn't even know they're
doing it because they don't even have a
requirement that their primary
contractor discloses the identity of
their subcontractors or where the
subcontractors do the work so a few
governor's and a few state legislators
have now enacted reforms at least
requiring that there be a public record
of where the works getting done so they
can decide if that's appropriate public
policy even for our taxpayer dollars
much less private sector dollars
the consumer might cure that a lot
quicker than government could you know
after you go be sent over to India from
AOL American online to handle the
problem and they can't handle it after
the third or fourth time I recently
cancelled you know my subscription but
we obviously don't have to trade with
company to do that also you can you
could boycott them quite frankly as
consumers I think you know the trouble
is consumers rarely have enough
information that's why I'm such a big
disclosure fan because I think the more
people know about where their taxpayer
dollars are going and where work is
getting done the more they can vote with
their feet so to speak and vote with
their dollars and I think we all should
have a lot more information about what's
going on than we have today
great point
other questions
one more in the back incentives are so
marginal and in business sense what's
your understanding of why companies seek
them so aggressively great question and
it's because they've become so lucrative
on an isolated basis just as an isolated
event we open the book with a case study
of Raytheon prevailing upon the state of
Massachusetts to rewrite its entire
corporate income tax code in a way that
would radically cut the companies income
tax bill at the time it sought the tax
cut Raytheon publicly stated that it
would reduce its annual income tax
liability by about 21 million dollars
and to win that change in the law it was
later revealed Raytheon spent about six
hundred thousand dollars one time on
lobbying and PR efforts so first so on
an isolated basis what else could a
company do to achieve such a fantastic
rate of return as spent six hundred
thousand dollars once to save an
estimated 21 million dollars a year
that's why this system has gotten so out
of control and why it's so lucrative on
a on a case by case basis for companies
to do it
and why so many middle people site
location consultants and other people
who specialize in helping companies gain
in the system have become so entrenched
in doing it thank you thank you very
much
[Applause]